last thursday large groups of israeli
settlers took to the streets of
jerusalem
attempting to breach the damascus gate
leading into the old city in order to
attack palestinian businesses
homes whilst chanting death to arabs in
a racist riot which erupted on the
streets of jerusalem leading to clashes
with palestinians
[Applause]
whilst armed israeli occupation police
forces
defended the settlers and attacked
palestinians
and over the course of two days israeli
forces injured 450 palestinian
demonstrators
but the violence did not end there in
fact the palestinian people throughout
the occupied territories in the west
bank gaza strip and also
in israel itself came out to demonstrate
against the policies of
israel inside of jerusalem
with the events in jerusalem working as
a catalyst
to a larger uprising throughout the
occupied territories which is being
dubbed by
some as the beginning of the third
intifada but in order to understand this
unfortunately you can't turn to
mainstream media sources
as they are not providing you with the
full context and attempting to try and
point this entire incident to just the
illegal israeli settlers and their
racist
riot against palestinians when in fact
clashes with israeli occupation forces
inside of jerusalem had been happening
since the beginning of ramadan
today we went out with this large crowd
to declare our support for the youth and
those stationed in jerusalem who are
confronting the occupation in order to
thwart their plans
the judaization of jerusalem and
damaging its sights
we and jerusalem joint forces are
against the occupier
as israeli forces had imposed many
restrictions on palestinian worshippers
preventing them from entering through
the damascus gate into the old city of
jerusalem
switching off loudspeakers at the
al-aqsa compound
so that the court of prayer and the
sound of the imams inside of the third
holiest site to muslims in the world
as a result of these policies
palestinians began clashing with israeli
forces who cracked down brutally on
palestinians and between the first day
of ramadan
and friday of last week israeli forces
had actually injured
750 palestinians according to
local sources and arrested around 100.
not only that but these settler mobs had
been in the streets since
monday of last week chanting death to
arabs and attacking
random palestinians with little to no
punishment from the israeli forces for
doing so on top of that both
palestinians and israeli settlers were
attacking each other in the street but
the context does not stop
there the policies that are ongoing in
east jerusalem at the moment are forcing
palestinians
out of their houses in the areas for
instance of shikh
jara and also siloan in these two
neighborhoods combined israeli settler
organizations are amy to
this year push out 2 100 people
from their homes making them homeless
and in the case of
they're actually trying to take the
houses of the palestinians who live
there for the israeli settlers
themselves
and these policies of ethnically
cleansing palestinians from east
jerusalem date back to the 1970s
as for the palestinians of the west bank
and the gaza strip which rose up into
mass protests and from
gaza rockets were fired into israel as
israel bombarded gaza back
the issue here has been over 50 years of
occupation in the west bank the
expansion of illegal settlements and the
daily routine
attacks and hardships faced by
palestinians living under occupation
whilst in the gaza strip
enduring untold suffering under a
humanitarian crisis
caused by israel's blockade illegally
imposed against
international law and at this point the
israeli government
can't run away from the settlers and try
and push them to one side and say that
they don't represent it because that
settler group that was protesting in
jerusalem
chanting deft arabs and attacking random
palestinians
actually has links to the jewish power
party which now has a member which sits
inside of the israeli government which
used to be outlawed but now has been
welcomed by israeli premier benjamin
netanyahu so the group feels that now
the country is behind them because they
have a representative in government
and they are given legitimacy in their
views but if you were to turn to
mainstream reporting on this you will
not get this context
and it is key to understanding what is
happening now and
why this may escalate into something
much bigger in the context of an israeli
occupation
which the top israeli human rights
organization bet selem has
dubbed as an apartheid regime from the
river to the sea
that means in the entire country behind
this situation that we are all
witnessing now
is years and years of suffering and pain